thank you
[Music]
so there's an Italian who claims he was
saved by anime
really yeah I like it already right he's
born in Sicily is that accurate does it
Sicily Sicily sound good to me Susie
loves playing with stuffed toys and
staying at home while other boys's age
we're expected to be running around in
soccer fields and having sex with women
does this sound like an anime
how old is he
um it just says so far he's born and
raised there I don't know
because I mean to me three now because
I'm saying like if you're 13 it's pretty
age-appropriate to be watching Pokemon
at home you shouldn't be out there with
[__] girls left and right at 13. well
well he it says he was born raised in
Sicily he loved playing with stuffed
toys and staying home yeah but I know
Italians are horny that's why I just
think that they're at early they're just
[__] girls left and right riding
their Lamborghinis you know it sounds
like they're having a great time yeah I
know a lot of Italian guys were very
happy guys
but this guy was shy and withdrawn he
should have been in Japan he says you'd
find me crying all the time what a
little [__] but if he's 13 that's okay
no if you're 13 cry baby that's fine but
if you're 33 years old you deserve to
get [__] up but if you're Italian you
should be [__] everybody all the time
in Lamborghinis if you're in Japan I
know if you're in Japan no no no no no
anime boys should be in Japan that's
where he belongs so his his so like
think about like this he's a caterpillar
you ever heard of that not like the
construction equipment he's a
caterpillar little tiny little
caterpillar
So eventually with time and water and
sunlight right and fertilizer they turn
into what is called a butterfly yeah
right and fertilizer and he is saying I
love her so much today he is saying that
he's a science he was glued
even at 10 years old to his television
set and it showed him the Italian
version of Sailor Moon which is an anime
series yeah good one and he was
fascinated about how an ordinary
[__] school girl could transition
into a superhero with the power of the
Moon to fight evil while delivering her
signature phrase in the name of the Moon
I'll punish you
and at the same time Dragon Balls which
is a show about dragons having testicles
it's so dumb for that
um
from Japan featuring a hero who becomes
stronger as he defeats his enemies was
popular among Italian boys yep but this
cat he's more uh attracted to the
nobility and the beauty of the girl
characters in Sailor Moon he liked how
their titties rise and fall Sailor Mars
especially she's the [__] one cellular
uterus also check it out check it out
she had she you know what it was irony
because she actually had no ass hmm yeah
smart
good writing yep so um he was bullied by
boys who said he was behaving like a
girl for watching Sailor Moon but he's
like those guys are gay because they're
watching like Dude shows that's true
got a point it's like do you want to
watch men all day I want to watch hot
girls he's like you want to Double
Dragon the cartoon show yeah starring
two muscly dudes I'm watching Sailor
Moon starring chicks with her [__]
little skirts yeah five of them right
and that's who's waist trainer yeah and
so these those guys were tried for being
gay and X-Men they were executed in
Sicily yeah tell me that pass tried for
being gay
and executed on the spot some people say
right no but he felt peer pressure right
he was worried about not being able to
fit in because he had these certain like
procrabilities to watch proclivities to
watch anime while other kids his age
were watching like other cooler shows
like GI Joes and stuff or like Sicilian
people held to a higher standard than
other Italians
lobsters
are they
yeah it's either you have a pizza shop
or you're a mobster oh I see that's true
it's either yeah yeah or or spaghetti
yeah you have to serve spaghetti though
you're 13 year old [__] chicks and
Lamborghinis yeah dude and that was so
that was the big thing right yeah so
then he's just basically saying how come
all these dudes watching all these Dude
shows aren't gay but then I'm going to
trial yeah yeah and getting executed so
he didn't want to go to trial he thought
it was a wrongful
excuse me excuse me what do you have to
comment about being being accused of
being gay and he goes I'm gay I watch
women all day they watch guys bending
over playing football day that's the
Eternal uh debate it's like when you
choose an avatar for your game dude
that's what it is you want to look at a
girl's ass all day when you're playing
it or do you want with my my friend blew
my mind when he said that he's all like
dude when you play water Warcraft or any
of these games and you're a hot girl
dude it's just samp because they think
you're a girl in the game
and then he's like what and he goes just
trust me you [__] do it next time I
made a hot ass character I'm like this
is nicer to look at her than than
creating a God Like A Buff Ass football
player character yeah like a big
Barbarian dude yeah and then you go
around and all these dudes just start
gifting you [__] dude I was like whoa I
don't even have to [__] go and hunt
this stuff yeah
yeah exactly well I like flirting with
other guys in this game
it pays off nobody said well the people
that's what he said in the press
conference people were executed no but
then they'll want a quest with me right
like I'll I'll be like yeah he won the
quest so we'll be questioning [__] and
we're making small talk and then I think
I really let them down when they go like
so like you know what brings you on I'm
actually a guy but I get a lot of free
[__] and then I'm like oh yeah and then
they go away and I'm like what happened
to my question like wait why did they
leave my group yeah yeah that's sad so
um they'd be questioning [__] he he
watches he watches like the dragon balls
and he's watching Sailor Moon and stuff
and he's he's watching the show and he's
telling his mom he's like you know what
I'm gonna live in Japan in the future
and he says he's 11 years old when he
had this Epiphany he added many people
show a negative reaction when it comes
to anime and video games I'm one of them
I'm three of them but I was able to see
myself objectively and accept my
weaknesses thanks to anime as he found
himself through anime he became eager to
learn about the human mind and body as
well as the secrets of life
and then he says that um he came across
um when he was a second year med student
he came across a life-changing an event
which is called Neon Genesis Evangelion
yeah Evangelion yeah sure
I usually punch you in the face
is that a good anime you do this man
what is it about um he was shocked by
their the enemy's profound story
Trails of feelings experienced by the
characters and my my little brother says
the same thing
while you know
while he was trying to tell me about
anime he was trying to tell me about
this exact one oh really yeah but it was
kind of hard to listen while you were
punching I'd beat him up yeah it's the
complex feeling and you know how loud
punches are it's so it's so hard to hear
what the [__] especially when you're
bare knuckle yeah it's so hard and now
looking back I'm like I wish I listened
a little bit because apparently this is
tight
so this guy he couldn't afford Japanese
language classes but he learned the an
entire kanji dictionary wow to improve
his proficiency and he's also going to
medical school this guy's smart he
memorized 4 000 candy characters in the
dictionary in just three months but he
still couldn't understand Japanese does
it not say that yeah is it candy or
kanji it is it's Kenji it's kanji it's
kanji but we'll we'll let him
have it he read a grammar book until he
memorized the entire thing there was no
controversy here
so then after learning Japanese on his
own for a year or three months is that
okay with yours out of controversy
he takes a chance he takes the Japanese
language aptitude test for non-native
speakers and he went for the highest N1
level which requires a linguistic
ability to understand Japanese wow using
a wide variety of situations he says
anime thank you so much anime anime
brought them to the to the promised land
that's why he knows about all this [__]
that's great exactly that's really cool
so he's in Japan now he moved to Japan
in order to take forward what he learned
through watching like dragon balls and
what he learned from watching Sailor
Moon and so Uranus mostly is what he
says
so that he could teach people the
inspirational stories that he got from
them he'd drive for them wait he wants
to go to Japan to teach he's in Japan as
a psychologist now teaching about anime
these people about their own culture
teaching about she's trying to help
people who are going through situations
and using anime as reference but anime
was his inspirational story for getting
into psychology yeah okay I got it so
he's trying to teach people like the
application of like if you're passionate
about this guess what you can do with it
Steve if for some reason you had to see
the psychologist and he started bringing
up anime a bunch would you punch him in
the face while he was trying to talk to
you about life no I would nod my hand a
lot and then as I'm leaving I'd be like
laughs
but it's because of respect for the
culture yeah yeah yeah yeah I haven't
watched anime in a long time did you
ever like one yeah what was your
favorite one the most recent one that
was probably Samurai Champloo and then
one piece oh those are those are pretty
old school I'll watch one called Akira
oh that's a 1980s but I would say like
was it yeah
but they're serious and then there's
like movies Masterpiece yeah because
there's like movies that are one-offs
and then I I mean yeah they're anime but
I think when most people reference it
they're talking about the series like TV
series yeah yeah
I was like at least they made this
Scarlett Johansson white chick Asian
movie so that's the best anime they ever
made
let's talk about ghosts of the shell
ghost and shell thank you wait did that
come out yeah Oh I thought they canned
it after best animated everyone it was
amazing anime but like the No No the
Scarlett Johansson one's the best anime
yes it's hard to make those live-action
movies though second best one is Tom
Cruise in Last Samurai it's not an anime
but okay
classic
I like your death note Death Note is
amazing
parasite Naruto and then I would say
you're so much cooler too uh what's the
one on gambling
one punch man
Come on Anthony it's about gambling yeah
it's about gambling it's on gambling
school oh I don't know is it neogenesis
Evangeline no no it'll come to me but I
don't think all the ones I like are Chef
no is probably one of my top definitely
it's amazing yeah so parasite's cool too
but that those are [__] good record
of lotus War
um magical shopping arcade I've been
obashi wow I'm sweating getting sucked
um
I like Maison ikoku which
it's not even it's an anime that's
basically a uh it's a rom-com the whole
way through it's one of those you know
the ones that are not action based yeah
yeah maisonikoku is just about a guy who
didn't get into college so he moves into
like an apartment and he falls in love
with the landlord and that's literally
the whole thing and it's like that
sounds like a beginning of a hentai it's
not it's very it's very heartwarming I
like death note with Willem Dafoe
I don't know the title of it but it was
like a girl in Brazil with a motorcycle
it was like South American characters
oh you know what's great perfect blue
and I think you would like it because a
lot of
um modern directors based a lot of their
scenes off of perfect blue
just like video with Akira yeah yeah a
lot Akira was weird a lot of Christopher
Nolan I believe is taken from perfect
blue really really I feel like a lot of
movies and scripts are taken from anime
so good chainsaw man so good but these
These are only one season hits right now
like here's one of the wackest movies
I've ever seen is it really yeah let's
watch Attack on Titan yeah I won't bump
me out I actually like that one that was
good it was good
started getting into it it's really good
and this if you just started getting
into it I think it's a good time because
it was it took like [__] years for
the final season to come out in three
different parts so everybody fell off
right and then they change they jump
ship and they changed like the the
timeline of it a lot so if you're just
starting off like you can binge it and
then stay connected but oh my bad I
meant Titan a
get out of here hey you know what you
would like Street Fighter 2 V you know
what that is Street Fighter sounds great
Street Fighter 2 V is a anime series
about all the Street Fighter characters
whoa teenagers and it shows how they all
get there wow
because I'll watch that it does but
she's she's like 15 in this
he'll watch it old enough
what kind of VPN you got
I remember watching a Street Fighter
anime And Then There Was An Origin story
with Ryu and guile being homies at the
studio yeah because guile was like an
orphan from American Military Base
Ken was and then that's why they were
raised like brothers yeah because I was
like why the [__] is this Japanese dude
Ken look white it's because he is white
yeah there's like five different kinds
but the 2v is the one where they're like
straight up teenagers is dope I hope a
white lady doesn't see this because
she'd be like he thinks Kennedale the
same what the [__]
ing I really have a white lady
don't send this to your job is to end
give your opinion before you turn it off
you can't just guess what don't ruin
this close it up what do you say Nick I
like I like one punch man uh it's good
it's good I gotta watch it he's
apparently by Japan standard rated the
number one like superhero I love one
punch man
foreign
[Music]